so
i named my talk government js but it
won't be political
so don't fall asleep or leave um you can
fall asleep because it's super comfy in
here but
um that being said uh hopefully i can
challenge
your perceptions of what a political
party can look like
and if you want to there's a lot of
links in this talk so
the slides are online for clicky stuff
because i might
move past the slide before you have time
to click on things so you can go to the
githubs to see the slides
so last year i or about two years ago i
quit my job
i was working at a market research
company and it was kind of
how you would expect working in a market
research company would be not the most
exciting place in the world
and i got offered to go and move to the
bay area and work for this place called
code for america
i'm from america um my affiliation
with that country is that i was born in
it and it's it's an okay place
however i was given the opportunity to
go work with um the city of boston
through this program and code for
america basically the way it works it's
like peace corps
but for nerds and you work with cities
so the idea is
you put these people who would never be
hired by a city government
into city government somehow and they do
crazy things for a year and it's a
fellowship so you get to kind of dink
around
and try to do something interesting and
so
uh this is one of my favorite photos of
me because
the entire time i was there i was told i
was supposed to wear a tie but nobody
really knew that i wasn't
because i could hide it pretty well and
the mayor of boston he's
in his fifth term now thomas menino he's
such an awesome guy
he he uh is just a really funny
character and this is us in city hall
and
it was a great time uh i heard uh later
that people would like there was like
this murmur throughout city hall that
have you guys seen the bearded guy in
the elevator yet this is crazy so
like within the first couple days the
idea of culture change
like the whole point of code for america
is to introduce culture change it's to
introduce modern technology but also
culture change into a city
and i think it was working like through
my beard virus or whatever
we also got featured in governing
magazine a prestigious publication
um and two of the guys that work at
boston city hall chris and nigel
uh they do an amazing job of uh kind of
they're like an innovation department
inside of
the mayor's office it's a two-man
department and they basically just try
to do
the coolest things that they could
possibly do to make the modern
modern government a reality um so they
got quite a lot of recognition and their
department's growing now
um so what i was basically doing was
trying to go inside the government and
work
with it and fix it and that's one class
of strategies that i want to talk about
um and i have a lot of examples so where
i worked
it's now i mean almost two years old i
think it's like
one year eight months old they have 275
github repos
everything that the organization does is
open source there's too many
projects to keep track of frankly so
what i've done is curated a list of the
the ones that have worked particularly
well but if you want to check out
what code for america produces um you
can go to their github
but let me just go through in as fast
process as i can
some of the examples so you can get a
better idea of what i'm talking about
and
their motto is all open all the time so
you can totally
talk to the people who write the
projects fork it get involved what they
really really really want is
if you live in a city to take one of
their projects and set it up in your
city
and implement a solution that somebody
else built but
get it into your civic context wherever
you live so
um this is called route view uh
let me refresh and review is in honolulu
it's a smartphone app that
you put in routing like in honolulu if
you go from honolulu to waipahu
it shows you a route and then along the
way it shows any
government-owned cameras and it can give
you traffic conditions from your
smartphone
instead of having to go to some horrible
government website blight status is in
new orleans you put in a property that's
blighted which basically just means
abandoned or old or dirty
there's a lot of that in new orleans
after the hurricane and uh
you can have this beautiful ui that
shows you the status of that property
instead of having to go and search
through records in a basement of a city
building somewhere and
this makes it really uh easy to figure
out like
hey this uh this is kind of like the
timeline of this property and
here's when it's going to get fixed or
it's not going to get fixed or it was
too cost prohibitive
we have honolulu answers
which is basically like ask jeeves
remember ask jeeves like it was the
dream of the 90s and
you could like simplify computers by
doing like human style question asking
turns out doing that for the whole
internet is kind of crazy but doing it
just for one
city government website is super awesome
and a huge ux win
so honolulu answers you do things like
you type in a box
how do i renew my driver's license and
you get back kind of stack overflow
style a bunch of other people that
have asked the same question and then an
actual workflow for how to
figure out who do i call what do i do
what form do i fill out
so it simplifies interactions with
government i should also mention that
everything in this particular
set of demos were all code for america
projects in the last year or two
preparedly is for disaster prevention
you can basically sign up
uh it's i think it's in austin texas you
can sign up your property
and uh anytime that there's like a fire
in the property or maybe a hurricane or
tornado
you get a text message alert and other
things you get emails that uh help you
prepare for natural disasters
um it's super important we have
neighborhow which is like a wiki for
doing things in your neighborhood and
kind of
uh citizen driven like tactical urban
activism it's kind of crazy it's like a
wiki for how to go crazy and
put a bunch of bike racks inside of
parking spaces and it's
in a bunch of different communities now
local data is like a mapping
toolkit so that you can allow people to
crowdsource data really easily
because every app that crowdsources data
writes everything from scratch and it
doesn't work on certain phones or it
makes a bunch of trade-offs
local data is trying to make it really
easy to have like a toolkit
for just having citizens report problems
on their phone about a place
which is a ubiquitous problem in
government hacking texas in is cool it's
like you put up banners on bus stops or
anywhere
that people uh can can see a phone
number in a
city and you can give them like a
question like
what would you think of a new subway
line coming along this road
text your answer here so it's like a
lightweight text message survey tool
that's easy enough for city officials to
use
this is one that i worked on last year
discover bps it's like
uh i like to think of it as like airbnb
but for parents to find
schools for their kids so uh boston has
this insane
list of requirements that's like a 27
page pdf
and it basically is way too much
information for
all parents in boston to read uh it
talks about you have to live in this
neighborhood within a certain radius of
this school to go to this one and if you
went to this school last year you can't
go to this school over here and
the this school has this after-school
program is what you have to qualify with
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
so we made it into like a web app that's
really easy to use
and uh it's being used by the school
district now this is another one that i
worked on
um which is real-time bus
data i will fight the nature gods
they are trying to they're trying to
stop they're trying to stop these ideas
from being spread
um it's basically like there was a big
snowstorm in boston
the week that i got there february 2010
or 2011
and some of the school buses got to
uh the school was at like 11 p.m at
night
they left at 4 00 p.m and they got home
at 11 p.m
because uh there was so much snow on the
freeways
okay that the school buses were just
stuck in traffic for like six hours and
parents were calling like crazy
where are my kids and it was 11 pm when
they finally got home so we made this
app
so that parents could log in with their
school account
and actually see where the bus is on a
smartphone
who cannot hear me everybody can hear me
all right i can put the mic closer to my
mouth
this is awesome we're gonna bring it
down
there are new this is actually powered
by javascript there's this company
mapbox
that does tile rendering in a streaming
fashion and so
uh my girlfriend jessica actually works
at code for america this year and she
made this map
of the city of macon georgia's transit
infrastructure
and she uh styled it made it modern made
it work on mobile smartphone
browsers and then the city actually
upstreamed it
and embedded it in their website and
previously they had a flash applet
that lets you zoom into a pdf
oh god let me save the venue really
quick
here's i'm just going to keep rolling
with it
here's a budget visualization toolkit
called cpenny work
and it's the cool thing about this is
that it's super simple
so city employees are overworked and
they don't
have time to learn web frameworks so
what you do is you sign up for a free
wordpress account and a google doc
you put your budget spreadsheet into the
google doc and plug the google doc id
into the wordpress site
and you get this it's like a budget
toolkit
so um it's being used in uh
the city of macon georgia to visualize
to the public a bond referendum
basically people take another penny off
of every purchase and
they fund parks and they fund new rail
lines going in but people never actually
understand
how the government uses their money so
this is a way that's super lightweight
that city employees can sign up for in
like 10 minutes and start
having open budgeting and here's
the penny tax in georgia implementation
site
and then this is awesome in honolulu um
you can adopt a fire
sorry a siren for tsunamis um because
there's all these sirens but there are
things like
i think they had iguanas that would
start living in the sirens and the
sirens would malfunction
so neighbors that lived around the
sirens can adopt the sirens and it's
their job
they get to anthropomorphize them so
this guy named his siren
vernon k bedua after his own
name vernon badua he named this iron
after himself some science have
different names
but now he'll get text messages that say
hey have you checked the siren this
month like it might be screwed up
and this app was actually adopted in
boston we built a thing called adopt a
fire hydrant
and adopt a fire hydrant was the same
exact idea but you're supposed to shovel
the fire hydrant out after a snowstorm
but this guy in honolulu set it up
c-clickfix is a ubiquitous thing now
they sent a lot of cities
it's not a code for america project but
it inspired some code for america
projects it lets you report like
potholes from your smartphone
then the city when they fix them you get
a push notification that says hey they
fixed that pothole you reported last
month
so based on that we made a dashboard of
all open 311
311 requests across many cities so you
can see which cities are fixing more
requests
there's like text message interfaces for
cities to use to report new things this
one's kind of like a video game
mayor emmanuel in chicago this is a like
a video game version of the mayor
running around the city fixing potholes
and it shows like how the city's
actually responding to triaging these
civic infrastructure issues
and 301 labs which is like kind of like
starting to convene a community of
people
trying to make cities more efficient in
the way that they spend money on fixing
the infrastructure
so that's fixing government from the
inside there's also groups fixing
government from the outside
such as here hi malta yeah
a short interruption um when the talk is
over
you all have to stay here if we
if we're stuck or else the place will
blow away so don't get up
i have a captive audience is that what
you're telling me
let's talk about anarchy um i already am
you just don't realize it
so this is actually a group in germany
in berlin
they don't have the word civic in german
so they're using scotland which i think
is city and state
and it's basically like civic coding and
what they're trying to do
is without working directly with the
government just from a community
activism
standpoint do the same exact kind of
things so they have this app wheel map
which is for crowdsourcing wheelchair
accessible places
there's this one which is awesome which
if i google translate
made me understand it's basically if you
have a bunch of bottles and cans
uh you can find people that come by and
collect bottles and cans
in carts shopping carts or however and
you get their text message number and
you can tell them hey i'm gonna leave my
bottles and cans out next tuesday come
by my house on the curb they'll be there
super awesome um this one is basically
if you request information from the
government instead of just taking it
you can post it here and then everybody
else can get it so you don't have to
have two people requesting the same
thing from the government
um and then they also have an open
three-on-one style system that was in
the uk
for like the last 10 years this fix my
street has been like it was like the
original three-on-one implementation
and this is my favorite project uh this
guy stefan
put all of germany's laws on github and
markdown
amazing so for instance this is the
actual law of the german government
and then now the pirate party in germany
has been sending pull requests
and so they're they're changing the law
and
imagine how mind-blowing it would be if
any city employee merged it's just like
oh it gets me so excited so uh the third
strategy
is kind of a hybrid of the first two you
have inside and outside government and
then
tim o'reilly who i
worked indirectly through him he's
behind code for america
he wrote this awesome essay there's a
link in the presentation called
government as a platform
so that's the hybrid strategy i think
it's the most promising one
and it's this idea of a civic startup
and the word startup
could have positive or negative
connotations but in this case it means
fixing something so what is a civic
startup here's an example from vancouver
canada
this guy luke made this thing that was
originally called van trash but he
changed it recollect.net and
it's a funny pun if you think about it
so in vancouver every time there's a
holiday
the garbage day switches to the next day
so it might be tuesday tuesday tuesday
and then there's a holiday and now
garbage is on wednesday wednesday
wednesday and then there's a holiday
so you can't recollect the time of the
trash pickup so
he just made a thing where you put in
where you live and you put in your
number and it text messages you
every time trash j changes so you don't
forget to take out your trash super
simple
also something that's super simple to a
web developer but
something that cities are not going to
be able to have time to implement so
what he did is he figured out he could
sell that service to the government
city of vancouver and the city vancouver
would pay him for every citizen that
signed up
cover his costs allow him to to make
some money
and also allow the government to be you
know it's a win-win-win situation
so this is a lot of the software that
still runs in government this is the
assessor
real estate system in new orleans um i
actually personally like this aesthetic
i think it's rad that they're rolling
with it but it's sad that a lot of
government software is still looking
like this today
so i want to propose there's many ways
to hack this system
here's one that i've kind of gone deep
with so
right now the way government buys
software is you have sales people that
go into city hall i witnessed this when
i worked in boston city hall it was
kind of disgusting there's these sales
people that girl chummy and they say
you know our enterprise platform added a
new let's say like a student information
system to its product lineup this year
uh and
so the school district is like okay
we'll spend a million dollars on that
and it takes three years to install
and then it's there for 10 years or 20
years and they're stuck with it and they
go through this process where they have
all the sales people from all the big
enterprise companies come in
and say are we gonna give you a million
dollars are you a million dollars like
we'll have you battle for three years
and they finally pick one it's horrible
they are
making the biggest like vertical stack
purchases possible
and then they're running our entire
government infrastructure and using our
tax dollars
to like it's crazy so
what if we had low cost procurement what
if uh governments could
like try something out and then turn it
off just like how we buy
i don't know service as a software on
the web today
and because it's such low amounts of
money you don't need a competitive
process because
cities can like any city employee like a
cio or a cto or whatever
they can bust out like 50 grand on
something without it without having to
go
through a competitive bidding process so
there's a pretty high margin uh for in
terms of money like a window that we can
start inserting these more um
like tech based solutions into
government and getting them to adopt
them
so to get even more idealistic what if
this is a crazy idea i've been dreaming
about for a while what if we had
a government as an oauth provider so
identity platforms inside of government
you go to a website
um maybe mary here writes an app called
register a new business dot com and i go
there and it's like sign in with your
city of berlin account and it walks you
through the city of brilliant site and
now i can interact with mary's site
and click a button that makes me fill
out a form about how to do a new
business
and then i click a button and it submits
it to the cities api that way
a web developer who knows what she's
doing can make the ui
citizens can use it and the government
gets
better new business applications and
there's a ton of use cases where this
would be a more optimal system
it also sounds a lot like developer
ecosystems and what has made these
companies really successful
but nobody's done it for government yet
um so it's
kind of like i wish procurement officers
had heroku add-ons basically this is a
dream of mine
so you can go and you can click a button
you get redis on your heroku thing
and money will start coming out of your
account but if three months down the
road you're like oh i want to switch to
that other one
you can switch and when he stops coming
and going so redis to go it'll go to the
other guys or whatever
and there's all these add-ons and
there's different levels and they're
plug and play and they conform to like a
third-party ecosystem standard
but again nobody is doing it in a
government because government is
dominated by these big enterprise
companies here's an example of an actual
place that is doing this right
freaking estonia is awesome so why
estonia
i went to this crazy meeting with the
president of estonia
don't ask me how i got there that's me
and that's the president of estonia
he's an amazing person he told me that
he learned a program on a pdp-8 when he
was in middle school
and that has formed and he's basically a
hacker and so
he is like he writes assembler and
he is now a head of state like how many
heads of state can write assembler i i
think like one
and what it's done is it's informed like
he has a native understanding of data
and privacy and all these important
issues that governments have to tackle
and estonia actually has these really
cool things so
each department in the government has
its own uh
compartmentalized data storage mechanism
for doing whatever digital innovation
they have to do
and only that department can access it
and the citizens are in charge of
allowing
picking which departments get access to
which parts of their data it's not one
creepy big government data set
and it wouldn't work at say the united
states federal level
but they have ribs and spines so we have
the backbone the spine the standards and
each department has a rib that connects
to the spine in a standardized way
but the cool thing is that they just
bought that software
because they said here's what we need
what company is going to make it
and they they bought this platform and
integrated it but they don't
run their company like a software or
they're they're not a software company
estonia is
a small government that has made smart
purchases and innovated because they
have the right platform in place
so you can do things like when you park
your car you text message uh
what neighborhood you parked in and when
the person who comes by
and checks your license plate they see
that you're currently paying for parking
it's
and you could you can pay you can vote
online you can vote in any election in
estonia online they're the only country
where
every election you can vote online they
rank really highly in a lot of different
areas but um they're not
it's better to think of them as a
medium-sized city when we're talking
about
adapting their ideas for other places
there are only about a million people
in estonia but there's a million people
in a lot of cities that have
very similar issues so another problem
who's going to advocate for this good
software we know that there's better
ways of doing it than what government is
doing
and bureaucrats are evil right so who is
going to be our champion
hammer that's who you guys remember abc
hammer he's kind of a big deal
he is actually from the neighborhood
that i now live in in oakland
and uh this is at code for america last
week or actually like three days ago
ron conway is a well-known investor and
tim o'reilly brought m.c hammer in to
talk about
laying it down from government getting
them to be more efficient um
this is kind of a joke slide but this is
basically representing that
this issue is getting bigger and bigger
people like m c hammer are starting to
pay attention to it so you know it's a
big deal
and we all know that government is going
to always change slowly
but government technology is actually
moving really fast
for instance in boston they have this
cio that came in 07
and he was able to quad or quintuple the
tech budget they went from
using five million dollars every year to
run their technology to 25 million
dollars
so he made technology a bigger deal they
spent more money on technology but
what they did was made it the internal
systems operations more efficient and
they actually saved about
250 million dollars overall in the
budget by better leveraging technology
the federal government the united states
spent uh something like
200 times the entire um like
net amount of iphone apps that are
purchased the government bought 200
times that last year in just big
enterprise software um but technology is
making big leaps and bounds even in
government
and why am i talking at jsconf js is
everywhere
and uh it's the fastest growing thing
right now it's ubiquitous
and if you're going to build an app that
fixes government all the exam
examples i showed earlier they're going
to have a js component and our community
has
this history in the last few years of
kind of
moving forward at the most efficient
route possible and not worrying about
legacy compatibility so there's no way
that we can change
all governments overnight but we can
define how it looks
to fix government in the future and the
most important thing is there are cities
that are interested in this
um at that meeting with the president of
estonia we're supposed to come up with
uh policy ideas on how to actually
like hack the system and fix government
and i propose this procurement
lightweight procurement idea and i had
15 cities
express interest and say hey we're super
interested in this
code for america has worked with like 30
cities so far in the last couple years
they just announced the cities for next
year and they include san francisco and
oakland
and they've worked with like chicago and
some of the other bigger cities
that have are doing a lot of interesting
stuff there are people that are being
hired as chief data officers now
so philadelphia just hired a guy who
used to work at code for america to be
in the cabinet in the city as cdo and
it's a totally awesome new role because
it's his job to just make sure that
all the data the government's collecting
can be interacted with with citizens
um so my pitch to everybody
is whatever government you live in find
a bug
figure out how to fix it fix that in in
a way
that uh does it better than how the
government is
attempting to fix it now turn it into a
product and
there's now this interesting like early
adopter network of cities
who are going to adopt it and
potentially pay you
to fix the problems that they're not
capable of fixing because government
shouldn't run like software companies
so i think of the node community as a
political party in a way
it's very self-directed people do what's
fun or people do what's interesting
and we have these uh lightweight rules
around the core of the community they're
very small
but people are moving forward very fast
and what i'd like to see
uh like with government hacking and the
javascript community
is people pick different parts that are
a little bit
uh tarnished and they they find a way to
polish them
and they're implementing small things
incrementally
and uh it's kind of like how javascript
has evolved over the last few years we
have a completely horribly ugly system
but we've been able to make a lot of
beautiful abstractions inside of it or
just see it for what it really is
as a kind of a beautiful core so like
government the good parts so thank you
everybody
this is uh isaac schluter's cat
aristotle
from the node project just so you wanted
to know i have uh
four minutes for questions if anybody
has questions
i'm glad we didn't die also do we have a
mic for questions i don't even know
maybe well i'll just repeat it um
to adopt them i'll restate it so
uh first there's uh many projects so
it's hard to find them
but you're trying to get governments to
uh to adopt them and to
be able to switch easily between them
and it seems like discovery is a
real issue here what how how can we fix
that how can we make it easier to find
what the government needs or why have
them find it for themselves
i think one of the things i learned in
working for one city and then going into
another city
and trying to adapt the same solutions
was every city is different
and it's hard to ride a virus that
infects multiple cities like you come up
with one cool thing
but one city might think it's cool and
it is another city might not
so you kind of have to it's all about
more people and more cities getting
involved in telling
the story of their individual city and
what they need and
what i'd like to see is more like local
developers working in the cities they
live in
with the cities themselves i think right
now it's only a couple years of people
really tinkering with this stuff
and more and more solutions like the
adopta system adopt a hydra and adopt a
siren that's been adopted by like 15
cities now
um and that's one of the cooler success
stories of like in the last 12 months
since it started
but it's still the early days and i
think that it's hard to find
universal solutions it's more like you
have one like the van trash thing how
many cities have weird trash schedules a
lot of
cities don't have that problem so um
it's it's complicated but i think it's
getting better
mary oh yeah
i'm interested in why the things you've
described are predicated on the
involvement of government
so the overarching
theme seems to be making the world run
better
but why is the government the sort of
nexus of all of those solutions
i think that government is so hard to
understand right now
that it on one hand i appreciate the
idea of
building a completely new system that's
not connected
um and maybe like rage quitting on
government and and
you can do a lot if you if you're not
trying to backboard everything
but i guess that that's a really good
question i think that may be like the
core debate
is do you try to fix something that's
hard to understand
uh because what if we could like know
oops sorry what if we could know what
our government's doing at all times
in a way that's not creepy transparency
but positive understandability
like if we could truly understand the
system and all collaborate and actually
do it together which is the dream of
government of everybody doing everything
together
then that would be great so i guess i
guess at a meta level i would be happy
with
these systems working in society without
the government's involvement but if you
did build a system that did work
it might turn into a government
eventually anyway so it might be
inevitable
it's a difficult question and with that
i am
totes out of time and apparently
don't stand up until paul tells us to